Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by audible as we explore more of how the world is
saturated in color from soft Hughes to violence stains. Check out brain myths,
exploded. Lessons from neuroscience available at audible.
Explore the myriad topics in neuroscience to 24 lectures about myths of the
brain. Go to audible.com/radio lab or text radio lab,
two 500 500 for a free 30 day trial and a free audio book.
Hey, I'm Becca Bressler.
I'm the production manager here at Radiolab and I'm here to tell you about a new
WMI c studios podcast called Cot,
that c a u g h T. Cot.
Do you remember when you were a kid or a teenager and you made a bad decision
and you said to yourself, if I just get away with it this one time,
I'll never do it again. Well,
our colleagues at w c studios are launching a new series about kids who aren't
so lucky. Caught, tells the stories of teenagers who make these thoughtless,
impulsive decisions and as a result gets sucked into a punitive juvenile justice
system that changes their lives.
You can find caught in iTunes or wherever you get your podcasts.
Be sure to check it out and subscribe.
Oh wait, you're listening.
Listening to radio lab radio from w n y.
S. A. M. It was dismissed.
I was already dismissed from the day I was dismissed from,
I'm not even supposed to come back to my own. Everybody's so elated.
And I was kind of Moby and said, what's wrong with you? I said, well, I don't.
I like jury duty. So you're gone all day tomorrow? No, I'm not.
I'm here tomorrow. I'm drowned. Oh my God. Okay.
So if we want to do this tomorrow, we could teach things, but yeah, we could.
Oh, that's good. That's good to know. Okay, so Robert, let me see where,
where did we start? But I think we start where we left off,
right where we left off.
We thought we had simply the most fabulous animal of color wise in the world.
Champion of rainbows, of champion of rainbows. This is Radiolab by the way,
Chad Roberts. So, uh, seven ish years ago we did a show about colors.
We asked a very simple question,
who among us earthlings sees the best rainbow?
We crowned a champion and we're going to reevaluate that coronation right now as
one does as time passes and science advances. So, uh, we're gonna here's why.
Here's what I think we should do. I think we should play the original segment.
Yes. Because it is delightful.
You hear as the crowning of the champion and then we should reevaluate whether
the champion deserves to be crowned. OK. And uh, the, the early segment,
it started with Robert asking a question to a cognitive scientist by the name of
Mark Shane Jeezy. Well, here's a question.
If a dog and the human and a crow where can be staring at a rainbow,
would they be seeing very different things? Yes.
Now this question that Robert just kind of tossed out during an interview with
like about how different creatures would see the rainbow.
This ended up taking us down a little worm hole and we ended up actually getting
acquire to help us illustrate a, what we learned.
But just to set a baseline. Your normal rainbow goes like this,
starting bottom up. Three, two, one.
[inaudible]
red, orange, yellow, green, blue, violet. Roy G bit. Where'd you bev?
Yeah, the, I don't know why people put the I in there, but that's it.
If you didn't have the indigo, you couldn't say it though. It'd be [inaudible].
That's why you need the, I think just to say the Roy g Bev,
you know that by the way is Tom Cronin.
I have what's called a visual ecologist. Mark suggested we give him a call.
He told us that human seat, seven colors in the rainbow,
and in the case of the dog, very different rainbow, it's gonna start off blue.
He'll be able to see blue just fine. So it was he a rainbow starting with blue,
same blue we see. And then grading off into
green [inaudible] same green as us,
and then disappearing. He would end there
with a tiny bit of yellow throne. That's it. Yeah.
So the rainbow would only be about half as thick as ours. Wow.
That's a sucky rainbow dog. Yeah.
That's why when God promised that he would never deliver another day,
lose that he gave a paper, I made the promise and the rainbow,
the dogs just for totally unimpressed.
And what is it about the dog guy that makes it see this way?
It doesn't have red sensitive photo receptors. No red sensitive cones.
The weird thing is that the difference between dogs and us cone wise is just
one. They have cones tuned to blue and green. So do we.
But we have this one extra
red, which doesn't really seem like a big difference. I mean it's just one comb,
but have three is so much better than two.
That's Jane Nights Vision scientists,
because of this kind of multiplicative thing,
red can get mixed with blue chinks,
purple or red can get mixed with yellow to make orange and green to mix with
blue to get teal or turquoise.
And that's how we get about a hundred different shades of colored that we can
see. So by adding one
photo pigment, instead of adding just one more color,
you actually add about 98 colors or so. All right, let's move on.
So now we have a cro unless you'd like to change the bird.
Well the cro is not so interesting cause it's pretty much like us.
So let's take a LSA Co. If something like a um, a sparrow,
cause sparrows have ultraviolet vision, what do they see?
So they see the rainbow starts before our rainbow starts where we just see sky,
it would see an ultraviolet color.
Then it would see the wireless
N***a oranges, her first,
and then the red and probably would see further into the red that has because
they have the more red sensitive red receptor than we have.
So we see a much broader rainbow. We'll start earlier and it would end later.
Woo.
So should we assume that we've now that this bow is the champion,
but that's the, that's that's as high as it gets. If you're talking about Virta,
Brits, [inaudible] thing that has a heart and the mind and a,
once you leave the vertebrates then all bets are off.
You've got many animals have much better color vision than the vertebrates.
Like what? Butterflies are a great example.
Butterflies have five or six kinds of rays of color receptors.
We only have three. Remember butterflies see more colors than we do.
Yeah. So if a butterfly, we're looking at a rainbow.
I know they do. I'm sure.
I mean butterflies are out there and when the rain are out,
but it was he colors.
We have no names for between the blues and the Greens and the Greens and the
yellows. Ooh. So it would go from ultraviolet. It would see that,
that, yep.
Then it would see violet and then blue and then blue,
blue, green. Yup. And Green, green, blue, blue e or whatever.
Right. And then an orange and red and all that.
[inaudible]
very complicated eyes. Okay. So just to recap, all right, here's the dog.
here's US humans.
Uh,
now the sparrow
[inaudible]
more based, a little bit more high end, so to speak. And finally the butterfly
which is, you know, not so far above the sparrow,
but it's got more mids in there. So I'm now thinking butter plot.
Butterflies get the crown. Yeah. But then you, if you go onto Carl reefs,
you come across these animals called mantis shrimps. What are they called?
Meta like Mantis, like a praying mantis. Oh, mantis shrimp. It was from catches.
Pray using an arm like a praying mantis says oh managed.
Shrimps are are mostly pretty small about the size of a finger.
Some get to be as big as your forearm. Big Animals.
I'm actually looking this up right here. Oh. Oh my God.
They're so colorful. No, they are colorful though. Here, look at this.
Oh my God. They're just like a, it's like their electric colored. Yeah,
like turquoise or something iridescent in their eyes or like little cartoon eyes
. They're gigantic. Yeah. They have two really big eyes right on the front.
And you said that dogs have two cones. We have three.
How much does a butterfly have? Again, a butterfly has five.
Depends on the butterfly. A managed firms have 16
1616 kinds of receptors. What would the rainbow look like to them mean?
Could they even see it it, but see the rainbow fine goes.
They live in very shallow water and so the water is pretty clear,
almost like air. They would start the rainbow way, way, way inside.
Where we see violet, they would see
ordinarily deep
ultraviolet and then they would go on through several kinds of ultraviolet,
probably five or six kinds of ultraviolet and then never get to violet, which,
which is another,
reaching our colors and go through violet and violet blue and blue and blue
green
where they have those green bean blue blue blues as well. Yup.
[inaudible]. They would go out into the rent,
so they would be about as red as us when they got to the red out,
but only in the red. Yeah.
What a rainbow that must be. Yeah.
They have the most complicated visual system of any animals by a factor of two
or more. Wait, wait, wait.
He said any do you mean you mean you mean that unequivocally? Any, yeah.
No other animal that we know of has a visual system within 50% is complicated.
Oh, right. Mantis
[inaudible]
but you know, on the other hand their brains are tiny,
so who knows what then too.
They may not have the ability to perceive the beauty of the rainbow in the way.
No, I don't. I don't know. Their,
their Venice from Sir into violence and how do we interviewed,
they go around and kill things. That's, I mean really that's what they do.
That's, that's one reason they're so fascinating is how,
how would they have to go around and kill things? What did they say?
Shell crabs, other managed shrimps. Shrimps octopuses they'll kill octopuses.
Yeah. Small ones are good size matter.
Shrimp will can break the wall of an aquarium where really, yeah, there's a,
there's ones in California that can break aquarium walls if they hit it hard.
Oh my gosh.
You have a pugnacious Mohammed Ali seagoing animal with incredibly great visual
sense
[inaudible]
special thanks to Jim Briggs, our engineer for the acquire session,
which was a blast to mark Shank Jeezy for setting us off in this direction to
Michael Kirschner and the young New Yorkers Chorus and John McLay and
the Grease Church Curl Society and those folks from the collegiate chorale and
the DSF choirs who joined us and to Alex Ambrose of WQXR for getting everybody
together. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
[inaudible].
Okay,
so here we are back in the present 2018 that was how we left it seven ish years
ago. And now we take it a second, somewhat more sober.
Look at this animal. Yes. Glorious achievements. Well, actually I get it.
We get to actually look at it like I, I I get to I n fact. Well, you know,
you met one. I did. I met the Cha,
I met the champ and we shared a moment, uh,
that I certainly will never forget.
[inaudible] that's coming up after the break.
This is Amy Plantinga from Boston, Massachusetts.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, this is Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by audible as we continue to a rip the rainbow to pieces
in this episode of colors, checkout brain myths exploded.
Lessons from neuroscience available at audible.
Just start building a more accurate understanding of current breakthroughs in
neuroscience.
You have to start by shattering popular brain myths to 24 different lectures.
You can explore the myriad topics in neuroscience like memory, dreams,
consciousness, and more.
The result is an eye opening adventure into the latest understanding of why the
brain works the way it does.
Go to audible.com/radio lab or text radio lab to 500 500 for a free 30 day trial
and a free audio book. Okay. Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Casper.
Do you know that you spend one third of your life sleeping with Casper?
You can make the most of your sleep on an outrageously comfortable mattress.
Casper offers affordable prices, hassle free returns,
free shipping in the United States and Canada.
Plus you can be sure of your purchase with Casper's 100 night risk-free trial.
And right now get $50 towards select mattresses by visiting casper.com/radiolab
and using code Radiolab at checkout terms and conditions apply.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad I remember Krulwich okay. So we,
we did the thing about the mantis shrimp [inaudible] and um,
partially because of us, partially because I think just the world was ready.
The mantis shrimp has become a little bit of a celebrity animal.
It's become a quite popular little cartoon television. Yes.
It has had. It's had its, its had its moment. It has had its moment.
Well and deservedly so. When you think about what we, you know,
we like when you think about what its rods and cones apparently are able to
appreciate. Yeah. You know,
you just want to close your eyes and imagine whatever it is that animal might be
seeing, which is what we tried to do seven years ago. Uh, but what as happens,
the science keeps going. And, uh,
one of the things that happened recently in the last few years is that the,
the people who study the Mantis shrimp,
they have released more knowledge about what it might be seeing.
And uh, we're going to update you on that, on that right now. Uh,
but first can I just tell you something? Yeah.
I actually got to meet a mantis shrimp of Kelp just very,
very recently in Brooklyn, as I recall. In Coney Island? Yes. Oh yeah.
I have dreamt at this moment, I must
say. So the Mantis is in one of these tanks.
You have one of these salt water tanks, producer Amanda and Ron Chick and I,
we found a fish store in Coney island.
It must be in murmur that actually had a real life mantis.
Oh, hello. Wow.
It looks exactly as I imagined it. It's snow. Wow. There's so cool.
You've sort of tucked away in an aquarium,
in the corner of this sort of dimly lit shop. The shop is run by this guy,
Chris Martin from creative crimination. Excellent. And this is your store? Yes.
Okay. And how long have you been here? Four years.
Chris sells all kinds of fish, tons of brutal starfish Urchin,
different kinds of clownfish. We have designer come on fish.
Have you ever heard of designer clownfish? Have you heard of this, nick?
Apparently these fashion designers are designing new clownfish so like you have
a Gucci ground for sure. Luby's Hong Kong. Yeah, definitely.
I should call designer clownfish. Just a little weird fish fact. Anyhow,
back to the uh, mantis.
It was in the corner of the shop in this aquarium of reinforced glass.
We actually got someone from Om Sri Lanka. This mentorship came from Sri Lanka.
Yeah. This is one of the stranger creatures I've ever seen.
And have you ever seen one of these things up close? Very, very stunningly call.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Well there it's just, I mean, astounding. Yeah.
These are called peacock because they're particularly colorful.
This is a particular guy that we saw.
He was hiding in a tube in the middle of the aquarium. He,
this was a peacock mantis shrimp as they're called.
So if you can imagine like it's got, it's their big, first of all,
they're like seven inches or so. So there's a big creature and uh,
if you can imagine the head of a hermit crab painted like a peacock,
stuck on the bright green slithering body of a miniature dragon.
That's what it looks like everyday through the weirdest looking thing that
you've ever seen. Yeah,
you can really see its eyes like swiveling in all different directions and they
have these really big googly eyes. They have beautiful eyes,
but we're looking at a peacock management is sitting in a lucite tube and it's
looking out at the world. It's treating the tube like it's, it's home borough,
which it would have. It was in the wild.
It's basically you're looking for something to eat. Okay. You said the voice,
you just heard. That's a Tom Cronin, our mantis expert from the last segment.
He's your salesperson. No, he's [inaudible]. He's an expert. He's an expert.
Okay. I mean, he sells science.
He drove down from Baltimore to meet us and remember when he was telling us in
the last segment while ago that the Mantis or these violent little bastards,
they love to go around and kill things. Yes. He was not kidding.
I just want to like describe this to you before we talk about the vision.
All right,
we're staring at Peacock Mantis shrimp huddle in the tube in an aquarium.
And Chris is about to feed. Know what kind of,
what's the poor little blue thing that you're about to put in.
We're actually gonna feed them a Damsel fish at a certain point.
Chris drops in this little blue fish.
It looks a little bit like Dory from that movie. So here it goes,
jumps it into the Mantas tank. Oh, fishes in
another fish is sensibly hiding in the back.
Fish is hiding behind the tube as the fish. Should
the little dory fish swim around for like, I don't know,
five minutes trying to find a way out. The whole time the Mantis was like icy,
calm, just chilling in. It's too. And then is it coming out? Is it coming out?
It's coming out. Launched out of it's too, but then
[inaudible] just like, wow, that was just so sudden.
You hear the snap is it hit it. I mean it made Amanda and I scream.
We just, we, it was shocking, you know,
cause they have these claws on the front of their body that they used to punch
their prey and you can literally hear that snap from across the room.
And then he, and this was sad. He then took a lap and then came back and just,
Oh,
oh just punch the fish a few more times. Wow.
That's, that's hard. That's a hard ending for that. For the damn finish.
It's been hit three or four times now is one of those like nature moments where
you're sort of amazed, but you also sort of want to cry. But so, so okay,
so let's talk about his vision. No, he's just,
he's back in his hovel and he says cleaning his eyes now after it killed the
fish,
it went back to its tube and started kind of like scrubbing its eyeballs with
its little brushes. What he's doing is,
I think the important thing because it knows it's got the best eyes in the
house. He was like, did you see what I did to that fish?
Now check out my eyes and ask for what those eyes
C R I r notion of that is totally changed over the last few years.
So a for that I'm gonna Bring in another marine biologist that Amanda talked to.
Do you mind introducing yourself? Uh, no. To who? To me, like I'm,
my name is professor Marshall and this is what I do for a living.
Do you want me to do that? No, no is good. No, it's good. Okay. Sorry. Hello,
my name is Justin Marshall.
I'm a a marine biologists and neuroscientists working on the Great Barrier Reef
in Australia. Just for context,
he, Justin is the guy who basically put the mantis on the map. He, um,
he was the first guy, his lab was the first lab to,
to notice that they saw color at all. Oh yeah. I mean that was cool. That was,
um, the University of Sussex. It's about 1985, 96 apparently. Uh,
he had a colleague from, uh, West Africa who was wearing this particular dress.
You had this wonderfully colorful traditional dress on.
She walks into his lab where he's got all the aquariums and immediately all the
Mantis shrimp were rushed to the beginning, to the top of the career.
And they're like, hey, she walked in and the shrimps went wild.
What does that mean?
They started waving the appendages and they show off all that colors.
Now that I know a little bit about mantis shrimps,
I know exactly what they were saying to her,
which would be entirely inappropriate. Oh they were. They were turned on.
They were all around and they were saying hello, colorful thing.
What should we do? So Justin was the guy that basically proved, okay,
these animals have color vision, like they see color.
He confirmed that with this experiment with colored containers,
with my districts,
you can get them to and just beat the living daylights out of a thing that's
colorful cause they love to smash things. Turning up.
Uh, that was all background. Here's the new information.
Recently Justin and his lab decided to ask a new question. He decided to say,
all right, these all these shrimp,
they have so many rods and cones in their eyes. And by the way,
he would say there were 12 rods and cones in their eyes and not 16 which is
still four times what we have. Right. So it's a lot. All right.
They've got all these rods and cones. How well do they use them?
Wonder what that means.
How well do they use it and how can they must use them for some? Well,
it's sort of like if you're a scientist,
you can't just assume that they see things the way that we see things.
I mean you Kinda have to make sure it's right. So I mean, you know,
his simple question to start off was how well do they see different shades of
the same color?
The kind of thing that we do at the grocery store all the time. So you know,
if you go pick a banana from a store,
even if you pick one that's just gone yellow, it's,
it's still a little bit green. Like is it too green,
not yellow enough to yellow. You know, you use your eyes to make the call.
You wonder, can the shrimp do that?
Can this animal distinguish between this shade of red and that shade of Red,
this blue and that blue. Can they make those fine distinctions?
Well, I assume so. Yeah, because they get all the rods and cones, right?
I mean they wouldn't have all those things in their eyes if they weren't putting
them to some extraordinary use in the obvious use would be more bluer board or
weren't sure exactly. But he wanted to be sure.
So what you're, what you do is you say, alright mantis shrimp,
I'm going to give you food from this yellow thing.
So what he did basically is that he would show those shrimp, a yellow light,
give him some food, yellow light food, yellow light food.
They quickly learned that yellow means food. Cool. So then he shows the shrimp,
a blue light where there is no food and naturally at learns to ignore that very
quickly because the foods that the yellow, it's not at the blue, right?
Most animals can do this. But then what he did is he sort of mixed it up.
He would gradually make the blue side,
the non food side a little more yellow,
very gradually he would shift the color from blue through to blue,
green through to green, then green, yellow,
just to see if the shrimp could tell the difference between yellow,
which means food and yellow, green, which doesn't mean food.
That's what we did and we expect it.
The amount of shrimp to have far better distinction at that sort of level and
we're surprised to find that it was the worst animal on the planet so far.
Tested.
No, no, you're, are you exaggerating? No, no. Not at all.
Our champion of the rainbow, what's the worst creature ever tested?
The worst. So in other words,
nature gives them a panoply of choice and then they can't tell the difference
then which the point of that that that there's something wrong with this theory.
I know it's kind of tragic. I am Benjamin Moore and I say to you,
come to my pain style.
I'm going to show you 50 shades of purple and you can only see three.
Then what are you doing in there? Like, I don't know what you're doing.
They seem to have the equipment to see all the purple, all the colors,
all the many, many shades. Uh, but still they've got these amazing eyes,
but they just don't seem to them the way that we do. I don't understand that.
Yeah. Okay. So
this is where you need to start thinking about color and what colors are,
I mean, according to Justin Marshall,
the basic thing to understand is that you don't actually see color with your
eyes. I mean, you're taking the light with your eyes obviously,
but then the color is received in your brain, right? And, um,
they have these little insect braids that don't seem to do color the way that
our brains do. The way in which we see color is
if I see a thing, let's say somebody's wearing a blue sweater,
walking down the street, a nice looking lady or gentleman wearing a blue thing.
And My blue photo receptor in my eye
gets really excited. So your brain is going to see that the blue,
it's blue sweater right now, if that blue sweater had a little bit of red in it,
the red photo receptor would also buzz, but not as loudly.
And it's actually the ratio of those excitations that gives my brain the
sensation of color. Your brain will basically say, all right, got a lot of blue,
a little bit of red. What could that be?
The Magenta, that's what you end up seeing.
Like your brain sort of paints the gap
amount. So every animal on the planet sees color except for motis rooms.
It's brain doesn't seem that interested in painting gaps.
So back in their segment when we said it sees a full throated wide voiced
spectrum of color, like just ecstatic,
glorious vision, rainbow view of all creatures on earth.
That's we said, and that's what we said,
more more variety in the rainbow than we can or than anybody.
That was, I thought that was our thought. We might need to amend that. I mean,
so they still see colors that we don't see,
but they might not just be seeing as many colors as we thought.
Like maybe their rainbow is more a series of, of rather
focused discreet bands of color with not a lot in between.
Uh,
I am very, very well, that's actually extraordinarily puzzling.
They're given the equipment that we used to see various shades of color and they
don't use it to see shades of color. What are they use it to see? Well,
they use it to,
uh, I mean this is all speculative, but uh, you know,
Tom Cronin was telling us in the fish shop that like the science seems to be
heading towards this idea that they use colors to communicate.
And if that's the case, like they don't need to see all the colors.
They just need to see the ones that mean something
least in the ultraviolet. There's really good evidence now. Wait, it's not,
it's not published.
So I don't want to talk about too much because it's not my work.
But it looks like different parts of the UV have very different meanings.
Like one part might mean fear. Don't go there.
Another might name sex. I'd like to get to know more about this.
Maybe another part means home. Who knows?
It's certainly varies species to species.
You were talking about the whole range of at least 500 species.
So to sort of blanket and explanation over that is a bit simple.
But what you're saying is that instead of seeing rainbows, they're here,
they're there having a conversation with the color. Yeah.
Maybe they just listen to their vocabulary. That is,
they have all these rods and cones so they can talk to the world.
Not that they can see the beauty of hand. This is complicated,
but they have the, they can do polarized light. Oh, do they can't,
which is so hard to explain.
But apparently it's thought that some species can flash polarized light at each
other as a way of communicating somehow.
I'm not even gonna try and explain that cause I don't get it.
They are, uh,
and unbelievably amazing and different system to any other animal on the planet.
So you've got to ask yourself the question why.
And I'd been asking myself that question for 30 years and I guess I'm a failure
cause I still haven't answered it. So you could call me a failed biologist.
I don't think we would do that. I don't think we're going to do
that. That seems really, yeah, that seems not really true.
If you had to distill the new information that you had, that you have,
how would you explain it? Like the,
the thing that we know now that we didn't know 10 years ago is this. Um,
there were, do you fucking weird,
you know what I'm left with, as I said, at the end of the day, I mean, you know,
yeah, it has eyes. We have eyes, we assume that it's eyes do for it.
What our eyes do for us, but apparently not.
And I don't think acquire is going to bridge this gap.
That's what's called an indivil cause like every animal in the world lives with
its own senses in a world that is defined by those senses.
And in a way it's one of those tragic things and it's try as you will.
You will never know what a batch knows. When an echo aides,
you will never know what a deer when it looks out,
because we know that deer don't see our injustice by all the hundreds.
We are bright orange and yellow. They just don't see that range.
Do they see more of something else? I don't know. Well, how do,
what's an own belt? It's UMW. It's, it's a great word.
It's the word that says that you are limited by what you can feel.
Touch, smell, see. Yeah. Know on some level,
I mean I feel like that's a problem that exist even between people of color.
You know what I mean? It's like I have,
I know regularly have moments with my wife where I'm laying nothing that's not
blue and she's like, yeah, it's totally blue. I have that too.
I have it all the time. Sometimes when I don't have,
I have no idea what you're seeing right now and you know that's the lonely part.
The unloading the part is that you can try. Oh
yeah, that is it. It is really fun to try
[inaudible]
so we'll just keep trying.
the original Mantis shrimp episode was produced by Tim Howard and Pat Walters
and updated by our producer Amanda Aronchick.
Very special thanks to chase Copan for a recording the choir the second time
around and to Chris Martin from Crave Graham nation,
Michael Kirschner and the young New Yorkers Chorus and they have quite a range.
I'm Chad. I've been rod. I'm Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
one final note, uh, after we wrapped up this episode, uh,
we learned that one of the members of our shrimp choir,
a baritone by the name of Daniel Thompson,
was one of the five people who died in the tragic helicopter accident that
happened over the East River. Uh, this past Sunday night,
we at radio lab were devastated to hear this news and we're sending our thoughts
to his family and to the rest of the choir and we would like to dedicate this
episode to him.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Casper and their experts who made quality mattresses
that cradle your body in all the right places.
Get $50 towards select mattresses by visiting
casper.com/radiolab and using code Radiolab at checkout terms and conditions
apply. Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by audible as we explore more of how the world is
saturated in color from soft Hughes to violence stains.
Check out brain myths exploded. Lessons from neuroscience available at audible.
Explore the myriad topics in neuroscience to 24 lectures about myths of the
brain.
Go to audible.com/radio lab or text radio lab to 500 500 for a free 30 day trial
and a free audio book.